[Music]
a language knows
operation the
background and astronomy
and yes with detail and to die
iwork and the
customer intelligence the parliament and
beyond for years of working day at of
real-time analytics squads iwork as of
look ahead lookahead they switch poly
living and  feature in the end you your app
médias sociaux fans how here is an anji
bank account
ok be how house becomes motionless looked
forward is
ok ever few people
thank you
and in my free time and play gloom
and him just board game of all time
and  since
corona beekman brad en dan can lily
fascinated with space axis starship there
problem
the that conclusion offtopic
so little bit or an agenda will
explain what and why
is this
transaction course a feature alex plein
de en fame en de architecture and how i
learn from  the feedback from the customers
and the buttocks yes can always is one
is coming out
now this transaction churches relation
feature the who wants image queen
insight becomes
so is it  a wire who do you do
it so what this looks like in the and
right now
so your staff and about that or or the
category heavy you are here money
you can also subcategory and those
who once he pedigree colt itself another
part one  kind of links who has that
categorized just now you fine santing the same
family bid
[Music]
new yes
furniture furniture for the
forest floor
and that was not get advice apprentice
weekend en
[Music]
being where you are doing the category so
change the category
want to enable this as a house en garden
en he lives to this oh be zo in the
future de bouer your family de it is
sides party we always be house en
garden for not
now why am i doing this jesus strategy
for an chili want to  empower people to
always have it in life and business
like weasley want to help people
manage their money and yes pray novio
preferred spelling herman ion met or so
wie has competitors and those bowl
bullies akchaoui in this pc big air van
anyway ni  et op i have speed and
deliver on this the things because
that is is pray of them know what it
looks like en
in production and right now
want to show here that is willie
realtime so then i do here is all
her from the left my mobile  phone again and
looking in
such a big the insight button here
jossimar
[Music]
categories and going to the house and
garden category and the other white and
vegetables block in then my angie to the web
interface
on the website well two factor
authentication nature
test then you can do it transfer to one
of my own accounts
why could i have all the flowers for the
garden so flowers for the garden and the
years at is must that categorized as
keeps its garni
have you eksept the single mom mobile
phone dan from
buddha  and when you sit there so this
transaction of one cent was kat gryce
met in
ja kent and visboer in this
overview
tabata album and the architecture
will expand works at least for
long time this will be like a waterfall
we ge  t different business rules reacting
to this one piece
of the transaction  dat wie fcv even
[Music]
transaction and queen in real
time already off
transaction coach who colette sol
internal coach where i become what system is
it transaction coming from where is it
going to
so stupid internal substance that who can use to
lay crook  to the percent crusie that's
an etm
people put me pulling way coincidence one
way going to their savings account or
and investing in account of in fight
betso die sick and
chain gryce whose ran with danny gets
more interesting
so bizarre transfers rigger transfers where
we the  look at sides party you can take tirese
the iphone or the counterparty
uk or the counterparty and mike
scout understand how import what is that
is kati graces companies in the  front
pocket
android year
within these two years comparing the
proble tee of armand pien correctly and a
tick de wang
order that has the highest
conf
that is this is the next up in the waterfall
where we look at point of sale
transactions review group on the one  a
put your phone de ginste journal of
dairy reform ideal who has tunnel
take and demo chant category coat
and it liveleak 4 film not able to
categorize picasso who the environment and
never euro area in free can account to
party
milou ket who so a text mining
bottom party taking menno field this
is right now quiet then a man your week
ready the list of keywords
with in the futures thus coming shorter
will start developing an archive base
model that is the train of all feedback
we've got from the customer's
social  your target can vt who wants
using
of course we have encountered the way to
use to check this is customer experience
and forced to categorize there transactions
it is the retail bu  siness customers
i if we do i do for bowie talent
business
then that central transaction chose
that told you about
and then i have to all these other
rules what's important note here it is
what who basically aim is who look at
this
so take frinstance
in  a list of counterparty takes that the
disturbs in always ow even table with all
these names and the look at that my to
see what category longest that there will be
new to my die the intro in a
bucket academy coat and finally be
used and a
so take  and then the memo views to some
text mining
now this is not a table of course that is
is a model that is bing scores to the
text
so hot this week ghetto we coverage of
remodeled ethical about percentage coverage
mini-z were able to categorize
ethical  or percent on the transactions and
the opinion 14%
according to in uncategorized cosby account
climate able to figure out what is
and yes of course some brother server is
more like this night slogan tournament
deal with the merc  hant kattekwea' coat is
really important
side potti take how is william point
so dull and tools there this point yes impact
well continuously euro x play more
about we have a late there at the want
to ford tell you will get him out of the
architecture
so the header is based on
kafka
so they this area the frame platform
for the people that because family who
this so in kavka imf
producers and you raise consumers so
producer puppets messages on kind
of i so iconology games that for is
this how not  op i swift
transactions
nvf consumers des ardennes subscribing
to one or more topics and everytime
exchanges message published on
who takes create the sloop tables of
counterparty can the party sides
that set cetra
so keep you out is who have some say
is dirty that's the start the cosby not
the tour kickstart the mobi  le with
information that i had from samber and
dead space 3 s labeling my you
the top
i scout the party names the toppix ai at
the top external names and zo design nice
the prior beliefs
of i categorization
and that campaign net with some stuff dat
he stood did who i had from
marien tunnel did seemed it is then youths
look at table stars
created with rice park
well this look on tables in batch so
every week currently there are
transferred to
en dat the platform met your school de
streaming dating  analytics platform
fire kafka to the streaming dating and
fun platform is built on top of a party
good
and a lot of claus
always full streaming processing
and the ever is in politics as the ever
eye look on tables and now this platform
is image in scala
his range is so expensive see that
image is platform and who is this
scientist for but also
squads we year able to the folds cold
because platform
well I hope who that fold
is a photo of an ap arte of edge w&i
audience lang which will you sing de
mens realize small don't know so long
so stay for a team great it a
line which forms that allows to
ja die project coder
without having to know any lang
programming languages
nou en pray dan is  who see this is point
the animal in the weather has real
purpose what the f
with that short is that we are able to
great who they fill this word via reboot
to the folds piemel models der zo de
piemel mobiles all models that you create
with  some other language seem like spice
trail but becomes what if
what if you can do with you can export
this model you trained and by span sep
m en l fire and this pml file can be
diploid to the streaming data analytics
platform so when a customer juni
den looks into the app and sell this is
cool so can say categorization hears
insight
indicates consent for me did ought to
be
used to categorize so consent is does
it bother another team colt customer
reporting and they p  ublished a message
on kafka its hot ones to laugh with
transactions categorize
so anytime dead and sorrow ron is the
transaction coming in it is barfly kafka
to sd
and there be combined
the information in the transaction white
information ifn always of this look at
amos and the  pml mobil atf running to
categorize the transaction
to diskette gryce transaction is then
sent back for car to cost and reporting
and from there it can be reached van
epia je
anytime the customer fishermen the insight
bicycle to the point fingered old for
the stick is that even  customer than 600
this transaction is not a grocery chibi
11 en wellness
they can week autograph it this week at
the croatian incident it costner
reporting and sent to
is jay is wel in fitz how she live u
can said well excited weekend gryce
de singles en  say you can ca because it's
lace party to be always a week at you
listen is you do the letter the
historical growth in sjz it anytime
through the transaction coming i  n from you
for you from the thorn counterparty
week autograph it the way you want it to
that je a bord thing is that i use the
three categories to make up amid
feedback loop
zoë us all the information
about a week at clusius to improve the
sloka tables
so that new transactions by a new
customer's benefiting from the knowledge
that i get from the briquettes cruises
rica croatia from other people
now on to this feedback look so you were
using basin in france and
found its
nou de bass en in french comes in
it  wit
yes is the door of knowledge i became
so must i want problem so
in madge in dessert in a wild animal
payserver aif lions tigers en berg with
you don't know how many der of each nou
die bean tour in the wild animal
preserve  and you see reliance toe tiger
send one there
and swimming they are not good so
see
from and now the question that this
person on twitter den arts is what is the
pro betty that the next animal that your sion
a  r-tur
is inn die energie weg ar case is
it
this world animal preserve you can
consider s kind account party take
frinstance
fit for free dat was de sport club en de
animals customers referring to label fit
for free essence en catrice zo maybe
sports for  may the wellness
and then this
evidence that you so so that chair that you
wind tones is you see people
choosing wellness sport of rations
medical expenses for fit for free well
what we everyone modulo is
yes what is the probability
that wellness is who is the best category
for  fit for free
nou who is modeled with the die die slam
ultimo go mobile
after him dat the great met mr met me titian
gimborn thing that a not new order the
window using is dat wiersum so evidence
that were getting about people
preferring wellness sport sorry
hoor  was it medical expenses and from
this jquery slider solution you can have a
dream
samples week review and multi-norm you on
distribution and that gives you the
probability of the next time you  go on
your tour you see people prefer a
wellness of sports
eefje a very little evidence about
anything then your
yes how you a sure about what is this
portion sometimes labels love evidence
for is such a category and yes you guys get
the problem get higher  than people
buffer sports and if i get a lot essence
about anything then you're very sure
that you're not sure that ruiz and
[Music]
now the one important
problem for us is that we leverage
explicit and implicit evidence to win
je hef  my ifk gryce the transaction to
that options each the can customer
he seen that gets gryce transaction and
tot about it and
yes till the bolts were directing i who
knows that category you're not only did
see this transaction
and episode transaction
dan that every i who  we this and this wet
who categorize orgy dick who knows this
and closes after the shabby big fries well there
is already on that the german
explicit really kind and who is stinging goats
already hey
jantje who categorized i  s too big
loss with eft the customer thinks
see the transaction
yes then dares to since i would have
great removes the category anger with above
whom sarnath evidence for labor and
inference pico's excuse the cash modint
so die on the evidence that who that wf is
artist how a and b
the problem is that we are not able to
distinguish between b and c and die
zo the who this is
who trainer and a hefty moodle became
labels
that customers week week antichrist
santing
because kooitje de stomach but
right now
something like that is quite new  information is that
this seems that this mobile is not
working and zoal jettas who hopes this
should be so this is the family
and yes where we do not allow and test
greenhouse right now it seems that were going
to watch out to the implies evidence
kind of santing  is not being
completely writer
that's like a time to influence it so
well what's the die feedback loop then
look like so we start that export
mapping like labeling my your
counterparty names dozen zarg  ar priveles
en am i get is evidence of the chain
gryce transactions and the week at
creations
[Music]
well who combine these two to get
posterior blew and en who is the passion
lior blew to say how to update became what is
the best category and  your content
who her that is category is correct well
this is the middle
concrete x number so fit for free teacher
free sample rate of elf or sex for
track speakers who god is
experts that the chablis sports with an app
from libya not great explore the
customer's  from pudding it and wellness
this is not a real example' bed in
machines tv i shampoo
so bizarre thing so evidence from
customers anyway met to get the
posterior
belize
well what are you doing so the studio
so content batch process the weekly batch
process
who t
random samples of so three strether
fission-fusion be flux a bit like
this who even a shampoo
we that game historical like a universe
where the problem tee of people prefer is a
wellness for thymine p  rocent
sport virgina in percentage brands point
nike rabbit 10% and that dry and wet and
what tasty 4000 of the samples
and what you get from this is that the
probiotics wellness is the best category
is epi percent almost
architect the efforts of this i get the
probability that's why it's really
you correct so in this case 15% and
even look at the éviter que percent touch
percent a sorry to the lorijn juicy that
this is the loost value so the who
could dilute her ninety percent dead bonus is
correct at  least by diet pro center
the time well you would be fries prophetic here
so it does not do you do that
probiotic
[Music]
the fortress who do is that I drove and in
real-time get the transaction you
come fit for free den haag wil  i
so merchant category chose the drum
take and the drum ai those in this look
on table zef at that time and it might be
friends since that for the merchant
category coat wie f elephants that the
probability
is forties 7% the king  admit the murder
academy coach at shoeby freetime sports
it correct you take the club winter there is
effective percent chance that this self and
wellness
sorry then go for the 15% and politics and
why is the drum out who was here
who in heaven of evidence for  the
drummer who with this dente get
anything from the look table
with those people anyway so that who
using this probability that wellness is
the best category so that was the ethics
percent
real thing that to create
the douche of exploration then in the
setup expert mens  the beast am this
about who doe is bitter like us and
sampling a
moment java ladder evidence that santing
is one category
then be just showdown category 2 football
die
with anybody who gives feedback there
might be and another category that is
correct
am for the rhinoceros  percent each of
the customers to show that although
category
to frinstance
pfd fit for free game wii essex pads for
this report
zoey give everybody sports for this
categor  ie and for this counterparty
that means that i get in plus the
evidence
built by in plus it feedback sorry
about sports
that has pillow people do already two
categorize is that
evidence that it should be sports has
dyke is x plus the evidence
explicitly even side  to be something else
so weekend experts the feedback of the
warm are brands that he tower
teach people that weighting so implicit versus
explicit feedback is that so easy
so by doing so experimentation who are
able to get x plus the feedback console
boot sport
so is
who  finds that king de bass en in
france
there are 15 percent probiotic that it
explicitly new anus am who show
though a chair 15% of the people said
and restart gadding if they explicitly
evidence about sports of the people that
were given their wellness and satin en
chenille mattie well it's shoeby sport
there
so we get more ferrite feedback which
helps is
small the look a table a better after
such a point who my figure  old also a
parents and ein that sex sex percent
promobility that it shabby wellness so
do wi-fi wi-fi body wellness and can
now that they turned year we name
sorry you can lee in better wit about one
percent of the customers
zoey invite it  east radars more than
once and there able to access the feature
with want percent s up to
now truck hey yes yes like this
out like i get my transaction get me
rice
it becomes kings it is that a human
it is 14 percent  dat we not able to
categorize
zoey right now I as in and
out again for waalhaven lot or so three
categories in detail
so your goal is who wants to train
first preferably and he raised this
madelon so did a to start categorizing
dust-off black  sunpoint this text mining
room which is now
my july it is so my new
label dating
it is naive base model hope wil at some
point free place this text mining how
picasso be more accurate than wat ws
export for links shabby
and tv er d  us to ebay swaddle
than i can also start to compare the
probability is coming out of close in
this naive base model has the
probabilistic that i get for the other
tools na dato problem requires of
calibration so a my first
explorations the the probiotic is that you
turns car van please so wet who you
together wide it so got the finger that
old
what are you trying and manage
it and gloomy in the coming mans
will go to full launchbury
start inviting everybody in big patches
and then out more features on top of this
is one of the first one siz suggesting
transactions to settle son francis if i
buy for two handed us of clothing and
you then return en de giulia here the wie
show per pain to lie the money back
wie don't want this this to reach us
then to inflate your
overview lucas idea for i spent two
other biological pant light on the
church pikachu but under your back
about will try to this will try to
suggest ok
you time to settle this deal
you might want to settle is this is already
kind of section which i think the
along to this year which is connected to
this one was or for cleats we payment
request who lives to do so a team
and him now if on line to launch and called
he will sell it once in this is a mistake
and the netherlands
' live again and the netherlands' to raina
and nexia b also to launch and drops and is
well and those people look ahead early
zoey hope at some point to be able to
connect this  his six categorization as
previous lookahead
so that your
yes who is good start kevin your insights
about jejoen your profile blew band
build ex eurosong grocery snacks man
for up to december 30 you will often
christmas so can't be a bit more than
you piece frings age
yes that  for sitting
thank you for you are
thank you and the furniture teak wessels
on this
thanks for your dog and migration was
reviewing hp
kentuck are that kind on the edge of
chukka guys i'm agenda twitch this
feedback process is can kind o  f als
oil between us and red barn i won my
ted conferences with one and live shows
that one more and gets more free
practice note of and my social not
before won a ghost pepper for war
where do you get dealbata
out bidon de destruction in place  before
we right now
so good point [ __ ] who needs problem
in peewee cidade happening lotte fink your
it has such a yes it seemed timer that I
have to flip like last week we'll
flip a thermite the league and
that ever for bit more evidence  to
appear
we de yes I think there is from concern
about the experimentation meeting
f4 showing 15% of the customer's
wellness set sports what you aore
we do it will always be
wellness for you until this experiment
is toon 12 is not like  one transaction
for once in wellness the joint
wellness and that unrest wallet
sports
who your customer keep you win is an
expert my group especially hoses
coil you start this experiment marketing
alt  time compli world just measure it
soenens who try get the higher than
5 percent or some kind of
category b
i knew did then who start this
experiment would think about
half percent of all transactions right
now is using the experimental category
context
ok you said very deviltries  in the
single thing
in place the feedback novitec think
you're off state to your get
les feedback is die everything the
course you catch creation is so subtle
of people there when you're
just to be clear were not live before
long just  zo the majority of the people
that have access to defeat your right
now have been a fat access for less than
three weeks of so
met yes the
people are going to start rory
categorizing les een les ze of course be
into her next end want at the  cosby
mitten waist toe in test en toe at
some point that's not it it wolbert
ja der dussen en nico worried that
people are all three categorizing
anymore the idea maybe not care anymore
no  touch using the feature
so sand and who did not the motor closely
and how could you monitored and in any
way
fingers monitoring the behavior of
how you use the feature
and jar actively engage in both
categories sub categories are coming
back of an end to you still
once in a while wie categorizing santing
oxygen using the weekend rising
completely
and the problem agents not working for
you or create an elephants yes whatever
yes the new level other people then
he does picasa
yes the sense of to spend time
we have hero tokens little bit  to the
people that want to activate change the
rockets have been centuries has the mobile
learning
thank you
thank you for the speech descried do you have
the coach and
here is the replacing expiration that you use
your
com selector detail for threshold
demographic them and try to
be on  paste in in topicus i
polite that for for my king fiji
but that morning ls and me on that my
sport for whining sorry sorry im
ijn dipper die no french om
demographic friday
now not using in die stereotypes right
now
now it is really
so a for every customer
if you want to personalize the moorish of
course if you say no no he lives is to
be sports van den ham economy sport
for your personalizing in dead
but just to manually do santing
zo learning from about demographics
we
age going to be a bit trick die kast en
de interface between batch and streaming
becomes more than just the simple lookup
relatively simple lucca tables of this
lace party  takes should be that it is
then it will either has ooby in some
sort of models of the who does not want many
more en pepper lucca nipples barbie i
yes i must imagine french is that wie hef
and look it ebola customers and then
how many times you  or how much i prefer
sir de
zo us en persen might have ciro in sport
en dat we then used at information at
yellow and sports to see if i see
something dat they problem esports  dat u
than maybe i like
nemi
[ __ ] not be sports be cause you never
used before but i had to make it a bit
more tricky we so yes interface between
dutch and streaming
tank
solder and this choir
[Music]
yes was wandering
audio de site al  [ __ ] categories to use
a flight yes yes for kleinpolder test your
categories this why collectors items
maybe the sport wellness brain models
finds it also you might
mission categories yes using this feature
and he catches is to be it off problem
so yes form
date a point of  view when started
building so who this heaven id&t about
what can your customer categorically must people
prefer to be in we've never headset ok
because amiibo jetset feature what water
bottle true you well what can you or
categorically people who like it
so this before that interviews be done  with
people to if built and
yes what week already customer journey exports
set to gather a tribe just what
would be a good set of
cagri angle the camp editor is what
category would using
wa  t julian right now necklace feedback
about people from people think century
were pets category heard
kids category
zo before i go to live
we annual planning of
coming together white between you it all
feedback and figurative dry and the
categories advice should add or remove
or combine
wat ja  that so make it quite tricky' to
the old de van teams en full peaks
there's a lot of things it's not who
change the evident
yes so that the en sir locker
yes it is already select is needed
mother and i did you missed initially the
great  red
big bang that who
who who start sex free act categorizing
income in transactions
so you know state do and income
b-category
well business is also other business
yder you because the subcategories came in
and with it the site I know you if it do
it for  the retail customer's for the
private in the videos
so dubio after us also categorizing in
paragraph celeriesalad us frank
equality
and antique fair any other categories a2
from the torah di  e
wat last tassel wat arjuna charge
customers to be care suggesting
categories people can die feedback
and right whatever they want and the
blood and ice king yes he must like to
have this category
because
if x plus it ran out think and our
people are asking to  at the thick where
we the country nemo from category
itself
yes that already mix it will i the sale to
keep learning of the pickets
creations because people can rename in
the 1000 mm die more wat week moments
tony en has they are able to greater
to  kat greyston
yes aids heart then again to
doezum and opion what
idea what the problem is so category
so much washing machine so indeed a the
rabobank have as frugal as nauseous so
you have the rabobank agm category his
factory a baby on you creative and do
okay [ __ ]  you think this guy the third it
matters if quest for land from the
hall t expect
yes
well we two don't
say they don't drive things when they
change a cats stayed transaction
yes dat  is the des site yes anyway use the
description of the trendy my mobile the
transaction to categorize
has dry spelling errors' in there will
be don't and lighting in place to
push that yet but that is within this
14% that you a dat olivia  villages and text
mining so that quite small
the moment yes you can still a few
transform money to your man for instance
and use different they take sides party
take your connections and manicure men
colette sinterklaas the tools to work on
you will come play that this problem so
is who sinterklaas with giessen yes i
just want one wil ella wit and then the
ruby ​​sinterklaas in the lace party take
zoey will then try to look up
sinterklaas in the look anybody
won't find it will be yes the f you make
spelling  the ever third
yes
be done deal with a 2a